So, da bin ich.
Ich wollte heute eigentlich schon
17 Uhr oder so anfangen zu streamen
Wobei erzähle ich gleich
ob sie mehr da sind
Ja, also
eigentlich hatte ich vor schon ungefähr
so 17, 17.30, 17 Uhr, 17.30
anfangen zu streamen
aber ich muss noch
in Discord
Sachen besprechen
Es ist ein bisschen schade, dass ich in letzter Zeit
oder die letzten Jahre über
also aus einem Grund
also nicht für meinen Channel oder so
aber es ist ein bisschen schade, dass
ich in letzter Zeit ein bisschen weniger Gaming-Content
gemacht habe, weil
früher
haben mich dementsprechend auch mehr Leute geguckt
die sich für
E-Sport und Gaming und sowas
interessiert haben, aber ich mache ja
YouTube schon seit über 10 Jahren
seit 13 Jahren
muss man sich mal vorstellen
und heute ist ein richtig krasser
G-Bait-Day, also ich mache das jetzt seit über
13 Jahren und ich habe relativ viel
hinter den Kulissen die letzten 13 Jahre über
mitbekommen
ähm
von
also gerade was im E-Sport läuft
von irgendwelchen Call-of-Duty-Teams
die beschissen wurden und Preisgelder
zu allen möglichen Sachen
und ich habe, ja, ich mache ja auch kaum
noch was, ich meine, ich mache auch nichts mehr
ich habe ja auch selbst kein Game mehr, wo ich Bock
drauf habe, vielleicht mal wieder ein neues Battlefield
zumindest, was ich eigentlich sagen will ist
bisschen schade aus dem Grund
weil ich habe jetzt wieder was mitgekriegt
auch so hinter den Kulissen
diesmal aus der Richtung
Valorant
Europa, wie heißt das?
Valorant League, Europa League oder
keine Ahnung, ich kenne mich mit Valorant E-Sport
nicht wirklich aus, zumindest habe ich jetzt wieder was
mitgekriegt im Hintergrund, Leute, ich sage euch
was dort auch bei
großen Teams hinter den Kulissen
teilweise für einen Scam
abläuft und für einen Beschiss
es ist echt
der absolute Wahnsinn, ich bin
ich bin echt wieder
ich bin immer
wieder begeistert, also was heißt begeistert
ja, ich bin immer wieder verwirrt
wenn ich solche Storys höre
weil ich auch
weil ich dann immer
wieder daran erinnert werde, was das
eigentlich auch bei, sagen wir jetzt nicht so
nicht bei den super Mega Teams
aber auch schon bei größeren Teams
und noch schlimmer bei, sagen wir mal nicht
S-Tier, sondern Tier 1 und 2
Teams, was das für so
ein shady Business oftmals
ist
und
wie viele Unschuldslammer es da immer gibt
ich wusste davon ja gar nichts
wie, ihr habt euer Gehalt
seit einem Jahr nicht bekommen, ja da kann
ich doch, das weiß ich nicht, ich bin der CEO
aber ich weiß davon nichts, also an mir
kann es nicht liegen und sowas
alter
die würden sich normal
arbeitsrechtlich hier keinen Monat
halten, diese Unternehmen
was da im Hintergrund läuft, ist wirklich nicht normal
naja und ich hab gerade eine
eineinhalb Stunden mit jemandem
im Discord geredet
die mal wieder hart gescamt wurden, was
eSport technisch angeht, was eSport
technisch abgeht, was da für Dinger
laufen, echt krass, wie gesagt, eigentlich wollte ich schon
seit 1730 online sein, ich wollte
mir mit euch mal zusammen angucken, ob es
echt gescheiten Sachen heute auf dem Prime Day gibt
aber Leute, könnt
ihr euch vorstellen, ich muss das jetzt
leider ein bisschen abstrakt erzählen
ähm
jetzt ohne irgendwie Team Namen
oder sowas
in der IT
zu arbeiten ist schon komisch, du erfährst so viel über die
Branchen wie Medizin, Steuern und verlierst den Glauben an das
System, naja, also
ja
das stimmt, IT technisch, Business
Enterprise ist auch schon was, aber was
mich persönlich immer wieder schockiert ist
was die ganze Marketing
Branche, nicht alle, aber
doch mehr als man denkt
was das für so zwielichtige
Gestalten und so shady Business
Praktiken da sind, also ich kann
nur jedem, der in das
Influencer Game einsteigen will
also, wie gesagt
ich kann das auch nur aus meiner
Perspektive berichten, ich gehöre ja bei weitem
nicht zu den riesengroßen Channels, aber ich mach
das seit 13 Jahren, ich krieg da einiges mit
ich kann jedem, der
neu in dem Gebiet ist, beziehungsweise
der vielleicht davor ist
so seine ersten
Verträge abzuschließen für irgendwelche Sponsorings
und sagen, Leute, ich kann euch echt nur eine Sache
empfehlen, wenn ihr
ein blödes Gefühl habt über manche Sachen
die da im Vertrag drinnen stehen, geht davon aus
dass die berechtigt sind
wenn da so Sachen drinstehen, also mal angenommen
es wird mit euch ausgemacht
Collaboration
für ein Video
und dieses Video darf im Rahmen
der Collaboration benutzt, verwertet
und was auch immer werden, und ihr seht
da auf einmal, dass für euer Logo
und eure Namen und solche Sachen
auf einmal Unlimited-Rechte drinstehen
hatte ich auch schon in Verträgen
dann fragt
ihr die, warum ist das
so? Ich mein, wir haben uns doch drauf geeinigt
nur für diese Collaboration, und wisst ihr
was die Standardantwort von Marketing-Leuten
darauf ist? Oder der Patrick
kennt's vielleicht, was die Standardantwort
wahrscheinlich auch für alle möglichen
Business-Marketing-Leute ist
die Standardantwort ist drauf
ja das ist Standard, das machen wir halt so
oder das macht man halt so
und wenn ihr diese Antwort hört, könnt ihr davon ausgehen
die wollen euch bescheißen
das ist das erste
Warnsignal
wenn ihr irgendwelche Fragen habt und irgendwelche Sachen
nicht dem entsprechen
was vereinbart war
und es sagt euch einer
ah das ist Standard, das macht man halt so
könnt ihr davon ausgehen, die wollen euch scammen
vielleicht nicht, wie soll man sagen
nicht mit
der Absicht es super krass auszunutzen
aber sich zumindest die
die Option offen zu halten
ja
so und ganz ehrlich, ich habe
eine so schlechte
Meinung von dieser ganzen Marketing-Branche
über die letzten 13 Jahre
mitbekommen, es gibt positive Ausnahmen
muss man ehrlich sagen, ja
also ich hatte beispielsweise nie
keine vollständige Liste der Leute
mit denen es gut gelaufen ist
weil mir nicht mehr alle einfallen, aber
bei den Leuten mit Hetzner, echt super
zusammen, nie Probleme gehabt, auch damals
mit Elgato und so, nie Probleme gehabt
ganz am Anfang noch ein bisschen die
Call of Duty-Geschichte auch, später gab es dann
Probleme, aber auch nie Probleme
gehabt, ja
aber viele andere Sachen
dazwischen waren immer so
ich war kurz davor, einmal zu
verklagen, ihr müsst euch vorstellen
ihr kennt mich, ich bin faul as fuck
wenn es um sowas geht
ich war kurz davor, einen zu
verklagen, weil sie nicht bezahlt haben
aber ich hab dann doch die Kohle noch bekommen
ich hab schon Anwälte
rausgesucht, ich war kurz davor
da könnt ihr euch vorstellen, für jemand wie mich, der eigentlich
gar keinen Bock auf sowas hat, da geht schon
da geht schon teilweise echt was ab
weil
weil bei einer Sache
weil bei einer Sache sehe ich nicht ein
also bei einer Sache darf man, finde ich
nicht nachgeben und das ist
weil dann reißt es einfach ein
das ist, wenn die nicht pünktlich bezahlen
ich muss auch meine
Promotion pünktlich hochladen, ich muss das Video
pünktlich fertig machen, ich muss mich auch an die Sachen halten
die im Vertrag stehen und wenn da steht
14 Tage
dann bezahlen die gefälligst auch in 14 Tagen
und nicht in 14 Tagen
zu ihrem Quartalsende, weil sie irgendwelche
Buchungsprobleme haben, das ist nicht mein Problem
ob die Buchungsprobleme haben
wenn da steht, 14 Tage
dann haben die gefälligst in 14 Tagen zu bezahlen
und wenn es auf einmal dann irgendwie 4 Monate später ist
und die immer noch nicht bezahlt haben, da müssen die mit
rechnen, dass sich irgendwelche Anwälte bei ihnen melden
oder zumindest
dass man erstmal
ein
Mahnverfahren einleitet
leider sind viele Agenturen ja auch in Griechenland
oder sowas, da gibt es ja mittlerweile
europäische Mahnverfahren und so
Blödsinn, aber am besten ist, man macht nur
Bürstens mit Leuten hier aus Deutschland
es ist schlimm
ja
kann ich mir vorstellen
die Aussage
die Aussage passt
ich mach schonmal
einen neuen Browser auf
Amazon
ich wollte euch doch noch irgendwas erzählen, gerade am Anfang
was sind deine Top 5
meine Top 5 Linux Diskussionen
für einen Desktop oder für einen Server
oder alles in allem
machen wir es kurz
Arch Linux für den Desktop
Debian für den Server, fertig
das ist die
Top 1 für beide
Sachen
aber um das Ganze noch ein bisschen
zu extenden
würde ich sagen
auf dem Desktop Arch Linux beste
als Einsteiger Distribution
sowas wie Mint vielleicht noch
und auf dem Server
Debian und wenn man Wert
auf Support legt
kann man anstatt Debian auch Ubuntu nehmen
und wenn man auf Red Hat
und Red Hat Enterprise
kompatible Sachen steht
dann kann man auch Red Hat oder eben ein Red Hat
kompatibles System nehmen
aber Systeme, die mir persönlich am besten gefallen
Arch Linux auf dem Desktop
originales Arch by the way
warum Arch Linux
was ist das für eine Frage
Chat
könnt ihr euch vorstellen, es gibt Leute, die müssen fragen
warum Arch Linux
was ist da los
weil Arch Linux einfach superior ist
das ist die Krone
der Linux Distribution
deswegen muss man auch als Arch User
immer allen erzählen, dass man Arch User ist
und
danach geht man auf Reddit Unix Porn
und postet seinen i3 Desktop
aber ok, um das Ganze
mal ernsthaft zu beantworten
warum Arch Linux
weil es aus meiner Sicht
nicht für einen Server, für einen Desktop
weil es für einen Desktop die beste
Distribution ist in Kombination
aktuelle Software
Package Management
Paketauswahl
generell
Konfigurationsmöglichkeiten
ja
einfach die beste Kombination
für Leute, die ein bisschen Ahnung von Linux haben
oder sich damit beschäftigen wollen
so
wir haben noch gar nicht angefangen
so also
das wegen Arch Linux
so und auf dem Server
wenn es darum geht, was mir am besten gefällt
Debian
aber ja also
ich lass mir auch gefallen, wenn Leute sagen
wegen Support Ubuntu oder Reddit
ist auch sinnvoll
auf der Arbeit im Enterprise Finanzbranche
Umfeld in Frankfurt kann ich euch
beispielsweise aus erster Hand berichten
von mehreren Arbeitgebern, wo ich war
Red Hat
oder Red Hat Kompatibles
was jetzt langsam aber sicher auch
schwierig wird, wenn das alles so kommt
dass sich Red Hat so ein bisschen in den
eigenen Popo beißt
ich hab grad getrunken
ja mal gucken, ob ich heute auch was los werde
ähm
warum Debian für Server statt Ubuntu?
Geschmackssache
die Leute
die mich, die den Stream
die letzten Jahre über verfolgt haben
vielleicht wissen, ich habe eigentlich immer
standardmäßig Ubuntu benutzt
überall, bei Hetzner
lokal auf irgendwelchen Servern
wir haben eigentlich immer Ubuntu genommen
Chatkey, ihr könnt's bestätigen
korrekt
Chat approved
yep, genau, so
wir haben eigentlich fast immer Ubuntu
benutzt
bis vor ungefähr
ich würd mal sagen einem Jahr
seit einem Jahr ist es hauptsächlich Debian geworden
und
das hat gar kein so
wie soll ich sagen, gar kein so
fester Cut gewesen, wo ich gesagt habe
ab hier benutze ich nur noch Debian
das war so generelle Entwicklung bei Ubuntu
das war diese Geschichte mit
wir liefern Sachen als Snaps aus
wir haben irgendeine komische YAML-Config
für Netzwerkkonfigurationen
ach
ich kann's dir so
pauschal gar nicht
aufzählen
und irgendwann bin ich dann
zurückgegangen, hab mich mal gefragt
Max, warum schlägst du dich eigentlich
damit rum, wenn du auch einfach Debian nehmen kannst
und seitdem nehme ich
seit dem letzten Jahr oder eineinhalb Jahren
nehme ich nur noch Debian
ja
aber das ist ja kein shady business
das ist nicht das, was ich meine mit shady business
das sind einfach überkomplexe
Prozesse
also die machen das ja nicht
zu scammen
die sind einfach nur unfähig
aber was ich aus dem Esport-Bereich höre
und ich denke mir
also Consulting im Bereich
das muss ja auch die absolute Hölle sein
also
das ist, die wollen die Leute scammen
konfigurieren wir gerade Arch
ich wollte fragen, wie du das oben rechts mit der Anzeige
eingerichtet hast, hier
wo belongs auf github.files
da hast du alle meine Configs, kannst dir eingucken
wieso kein Arch-Server
weil ich finde, dass
die Vorteile von Arch, wie so top-aktuelle
Software und das
Our-Repo-From-Source-Kompilieren und sowas
oder zumindest die Möglichkeit
dazu, auf dem Server nicht so wichtig
sind. Ich brauche auf dem Server eher stabile
Software als top-aktuelle Software
und irgendwelche Sachen selbst kompilieren
aus zweifelhaften Quellen
vielleicht noch runtergeladen, will ich auf meinem
Server auch nicht unbedingt
also
Arch ist, finde ich
eher was für einen Desktop und da ist es das Beste
was es gibt, auf dem Server
bevorzuge ich tatsächlich Debian
jo
ne aber Leute, ganz ehrlich
ich habe jetzt eineinhalb Stunden
also, genau, jetzt kann ich
erst mal fertig erzählen, was ich eigentlich sagen wollte
was, JetBrains Rust, haben die
jetzt ein Rust-IDE?
ne, Rust-Plugin, ja das kenne ich
du musst Windows auf der Arbeit benutzen
oh, PainzChamp, ja ich auch
aber ich habe zum Glück meine Linux-VM auf der ich
Root-Rechte habe
WSL haben sie bei uns noch nicht mal geschafft
so, also
was ich eigentlich ganz am Anfang
jetzt erzählen wollte, also warum ich
heute ein bisschen später da bin, ich habe gerade eineinhalb Stunden
mit jemandem im Discord geredet
der, ich muss jetzt ein bisschen
aufpassen, also
ich will ja keine Teamnamen oder so erzählen, ja
der hat jahrelang
also den kenne ich, der managt auch so ein paar
hat auch schon ein paar Placements für mich
gemanagt und sowas und
die kenne ich auch schon eine Weile
und
von ihm habe ich jetzt mitgekriegt
dass ganz
shady Sachen wieder im
Valorant
Business laufen
es ist nicht wirklich S-Tier
es ist eher so Tier 1, so Europa
Valorant League oder was es da gibt
Leute, ihr könnt euch nicht vorstellen, wie viel
da wieder gescamt wird, beziehungsweise
wie viel shady Sachen da wieder am Laufen
sind, was ich da für Storys gehört habe
eher
so nach dem Motto, Spieler können
nicht bezahlt werden, weil angeblich
keine Überweisungen gehen
also allein schon bei solchen Aussagen denkt man sich
so, alter, was ist mit euch los
ihr macht ja auch
dickes E-Sport Business und ihr könnt nicht mal
Überweisungen machen
es würden angeblich keine Überweisungen gehen
und da ist dann, ist die
Aussage gefallen
wenn ihr zur Dreamhack fahrt, bezahlen
wir euch in bar
da sind die zur Dreamhack gefahren
ihr müsst euch jetzt mal auf der Zunge zergehen lassen
die sind zur Dreamhack gefahren
und haben auf ihr Gehalt gewartet
die sind quasi
wie sagt man so, auf den eigenen
Nacken auf die Dreamhack gefahren
das muss man sich immer auf der Zunge zergehen lassen
das ist eine professionelle E-Sport Organisation
dass das so Dinger überhaupt sind
die sind auf die, Dreamhack ist ja nicht irgendein so random
Event, ja
die sind auf die Dreamhack gefahren
quasi auf eigene
Bezahlung, beziehungsweise
auf die Bezahlung von ihrem
Coach, mit dem habe ich auch geredet
gerade und
da haben die ihnen gesagt, okay
wir bezahlen euch dann
bar, weil Überweisung geht nicht
und da muss man sich mal vorstellen
den ersten Tag
gab es kein Geld, weil es schon so spät war
den zweiten Tag
gab es kein Geld, weil
man kann von der Sparkasse
nicht genug Geld abheben
und am dritten Tag gab es kein Geld
weil der Typ, der ihnen das Gehalt bezahlen wollte
schnell zum Flugzeug musste und keine Zeit
mehr hatte
wenn das nicht Scam ist, Alter
da saßen die, da saßen die da
vollkommen verzweifelt
kein Gehalt, schon seit einem
halben Jahr irgendwie Gehalt überfällig
und der eigentliche Manager
von dieser E-Sport-Org
haut einfach ab
solche Dinge, Alter, da greife ich mir echt
auf den Kopf, was das für shady Business
Praktiken immer sind
die Geschichte
ist
mit dem
Spieler bekommen nichts zu essen, hatte ich euch
schon mal erzählt, oder?
Anzeige ist raus
ganz ehrlich
die spielen damit
wisst ihr, wisst ihr wie die das machen?
Wo wir gerade beim
Schema
beim Schema shady Business sind
wisst ihr wie die das machen?
Die haben ja oftmals sehr junge Spieler
die einfach nicht
die Situation überblicken
und die haben oftmals halt auch Spieler aus dem Ausland
und sei es aus Russland
Weißrussland oder vielleicht irgendwie
Südamerika oder irgendwie sowas
und
überlegt euch mal
überlegt euch mal, ihr seid ein Spieler
sagen wir mal aus
sonst wo, aus Russland
und ihr seid jetzt
irgendwo in Italien oder irgendwo sonst wo
im Teamhaus
und ihr bekommt kein Geld
und
im Prinzip habt ihr nur die Wahl
ihr haut jetzt richtig auf den Putz
und die setzen euch vor die Tür
oder
ihr macht weiter
mit so gut wie keiner Bezahlung
also wisst ihr wie ich meine
die haben die Leute wirklich in der Hand
bei diesen Orgas
oftmals
also was, wie gesagt
diese
als normaler Arbeitgeber hier in Deutschland
würden diesen ganzen Organisationen keinen Monat überleben
die würden verklagt ohne Ende
aber ein russischer Spieler
überlegt sich das zweimal
da überlegt sich das zweimal
ob er das macht
oder ob er sich abspeisen lässt mit
übrigens auch eine Sache die mir erzählt wurde
die schulden
den Spielern
zumindest so wie mir das berichtet wurde
die schulden den Spielern
seit über einem Jahr das Gehalt
unter anderem für die ganze Saison
und die haben einfach gesagt sie bezahlen das nicht
und wenn sie jetzt
und wenn sie jetzt stänkern
weiter öffentlich auf Twitter
dann bekommen sie gar nichts
und wenn sie jetzt aber die Klappe halten
und alle ihre Twitter-Posts löschen
dann bekommen sie einmalig 6.000 Euro
Leute da gehts ab im Hintergrund
über was gerade geredet wird
über shady E-Sport Organisationen
weil ich seit 13 Jahren Youtube mache
und einiges mitbekommen habe
und mir ernsthaft überlege ob ich da nicht mal ein Video
zumachen soll
das war ein Beispiel
das war eine relativ aktuelle Sache die ich gehört habe
es ist
es ist so
man glaubt das gar nicht
das sind teilweise große Organisationen
mit 100.000 plus Followern
auf Twitter und so
mehrere Teams
man versteht gar nicht warum das so shady Business ist
kann ich nicht
ja
wir würden das nicht machen
aber ihr müsst euch doch mal in die Lage
versetzt euch mal in die Lage
ihr seid ein gerade 18 gewordener Spieler
aus Russland
der hierher ins Teamhaus geht
die haben die Leute komplett in der Hand
die können denen sonst was erzählen
die verstehen kein Wort Deutsch
die verstehen nicht richtig Englisch
das Einzige was sie kennen ist das Teamhaus von innen
und ihr jeweiliges Game den ganzen Tag grinden
und sowas wird ausgenutzt
das ist echt unterste Schublade
aber es passiert halt
und die Leute haben gar nicht so richtig die
die
die Erkenntnis wie man sich da jetzt gescheit
dagegen wehren sollte
ja die Story
die Story mit dem
Chico
Chico wird ne Runde Whiskas Knuspe
verspeisen dazu erstmal
die Story mit den Spielern
die die Küche nicht benutzen durften
hab ich euch schon mal erzählt oder
ist auch so ne E-Sport Orga Story
die ich gehört hab in meinen 13 Jahren
Youtube Business
und zwar
ich glaub hab ich euch schon mal
erzählt und zwar
es gab nen Trainingscamp
haben sie gemietet
in nen Haus
quasi Teamhaus für 2 Wochen
ja
ähm
wollt ich jetzt genau
also sie haben
Teamhaus angemietet quasi
für 2 Wochen
beziehungsweise sich eingemietet in nem Teamhaus
ich weiß es nicht mehr so ganz genau wie das gewesen ist
und
die Spieler fahren dahin
und fangen an zu trainieren und zu spielen
das ist
glaubt mir das ist für uns
alles irgendwie logisch
ja wenn ich mich
wenn ich nicht bezahlt werden würde würde ich einfach
nicht mehr arbeiten
aber man muss sich wirklich mal in die Situation
reinversetzen das sind
Spieler teilweise aus
recht armen Verhältnissen
beispielsweise aus Russland
Tier 2
Team
die haben zwar nen Vertrag
aber die haben
die sind in nem fremden Land
die sind der Sache komplett ausgeliefert
die kriegen gesagt entweder hältst du die
Klappe oder wir setzen dich vor die Tür
du kannst kein Deutsch
du kannst kein Englisch du bist in nem fremden Land
du hast nie
ne Ausbildung gemacht du hattest nie nen Job
du bist gerade 18 geworden von daheim weg
weil du Progamer werden wolltest
und solche Leute gehts ja da teilweise auch
und die sind verzweifelt
und wenn die gesagt bekommen okay
ja in deinem Vertrag steht zwar
40.000 Euro Gehalt
aber wir bezahlen maximal
8.000 Euro jetzt sofort
klär dich damit einverstanden
und verlier nie nen Wort drüber
die unterschreiben das
welches sag ich nicht
eventuell
also falls ich ein Video so aufnehme
vielleicht kommt man drauf
es waren mehrere
die Storys die ich übrigens erzähle es geht nicht nur um eins
wie gesagt ich hab die vergangenen 13 Jahre
einige Sachen mitgekriegt
von unterschiedlichsten Teams
zumindest um nochmal kurz
die Story mit der Küche
anzusprechen und zwar
sie mieten sich ein
muss ja ein deutsches sein
nicht zwangsläufig
es geht um Europa
in dem Fall
also wir reden in keinem Fall
in keinem Fall muss man sagen
um irgendwie Counterstrike S-Tier Teams
oder so da mag das vielleicht nicht so laufen
ich glaube nicht dass es bei
keine Ahnung wer Essen kann
dass es bei Nip oder so in der Richtung läuft
das glaube ich beim besten Willen nicht
aber sobald man ein bisschen unter S-Tier geht
fängt es schon an mit den shady Sachen
zumindest die Geschichte
die Geschichte mit der
mit der Küche also
die haben
sich eingemietet in einem Teamhaus
das ist wieder ein anderes Team
die haben sich eingemietet in einem Teamhaus
und
wollten dort 2 Wochen
trainieren
12 Stunden am Tag
voll kreiselkreis in ihrem Game
und
irgendwann kam dann raus
es gibt für die dort
nichts zu essen
die haben sich eingemietet in dem Haus
aber die Spieler durften die Küche nicht benutzen
die wollten
in die Küche gehen da hat man zu ihnen gesagt
nein die Küche hier macht es mal
bei euch auf dem Zimmer Küche für euch
nicht erlaubt
Moment aber wir müssen noch
was essen wir können doch nicht
12 Stunden am Tag
kreiselkreis machen
wir müssen noch was
essen und da wurde ihnen gesagt
euer Coach kümmert sich da drum
der Coach sagt Moment wie
ich kümmere mich da drum
ich habe von euch nicht einmal Geld gesehen
für Verpflegung
von was soll ich mich denn da drum
kümmern
so und das ging dann
ein bisschen hin und her
und wisst ihr wie das im Endeffekt gelaufen ist
es ist so gelaufen
dass der Coach für mich ab und zu
auch schon ein paar Marketing Sachen
und
Management Sachen übernommen hat
für den Youtube Channel
Sponsorings und sowas
klar gemacht hat
und ich habe ihm gesagt
hier weißt du was
du hast mir doch schon lange keine Rechnung mehr dafür geschrieben
dann hat er mir eine Rechnung
geschickt für seine
Management Leistung quasi
und ich habe
ihm per Paypal 400 Euro oder so
überwiesen
und das muss man sich mal auf der Zunge zeigen
der hat das Geld auch wirklich verdient
also ich hätte ihm auch sowas
ohne dass der irgendwie Not am Mann gewesen war
hätte er die Rechnung geschrieben
wir machen das immer sehr unregelmäßig
also er hat das auf jeden Fall komplett verdient
wenn er was macht gibt er sich
immer richtig viel Mühe bei
und
der ist dann von her gegangen und hat quasi
von seinem, nennen wir es mal
Management
von seinem, Gehalt kann man es ja nicht nennen
ich bezahle ja keine Gehälter sonst nicht
dass das Finanzamt auch kommt
von seiner Management Prämie können wir das mal nennen
oder wie auch immer
die korrekte Bezeichnung ist
Vergütung, ja
von seiner Management Vergütung
die rein ihm gehört hat
das war
was ich ihm überwiesen habe für Dienstleistungen
die er erbracht hat
für mich
ist er hergegangen und hat seinen Spielern
was zu essen gekauft
im Trainingslager
und jetzt dürft ihr mal raten
hat er das Geld jemals wieder gesehen
für das er da in Vorleistung getreten ist
ich gebe zu
rhetorische Frage
natürlich nicht
sonst würde ich das nicht erzählen
nein, er hat das Geld nicht wieder gesehen
und das muss man, das kanns
nicht sein, ja
das ist wirklich mega shady
Business, eSport
und was mich
besonders triggert dabei
ist das von, also
alle Fälle die ich so mitbekommen habe
die letzten 13 Jahre und wie gesagt
es war nicht immer von dem gleichen und auch nicht immer die gleichen Teams
also das hat schon ein gewisses System
wenn man nicht gerade von absoluten S-Tier Teams
ähm
reden, wo die Millionen
locker, locker sitzen
ah shit, jetzt habe ich vergessen was ich eigentlich
sagen wollte, ähm
ja genau, was mich immer so triggert ist
dass die Verantwortlichen dort
immer so auf
ahnungslos machen
ich habe Chatverläufe gesehen, Leute
da kannst du nur mit dem Kopf schütteln
der CEO
weiß von nix immer
wie oft ich
wie oft ich Chatverläufe da
gesehen habe von irgendwelchen Verantwortlichen
in diesen Organisationen, die immer
nichts wussten von dem was passiert
wo man sich fragt, alter
du bist der fucking CEO
die nerven dich seit über nem Jahr, dass sie ihr Gehalt
bekommen und du weißt von nix
was bist du denn für
ein CEO, es gibt zwei Möglichkeiten
entweder du unterstützt den Scam
dann bist du ein Arsch
oder du hast keine Ahnung was in dem Laden läuft
dann bist du ein scheiß CEO
es gibt eigentlich nur diese zwei Möglichkeiten
alter
wie jetzt
jetzt was ist mit euch, wie können die
davon nichts wissen dann
und
also ohne scheiß
die größten Unschuldslemmer
im Marketingbereich
sind eigentlich die, die am besten Bescheid wissen
was für ne Kacke immer läuft
das ist ein bisschen wie beim Fußball
wenn die sich hinschmeißen, oh mein Bein ist gebrochen
alter ich sterbe, alter ich sterbe
okay let's go, weiter geht's
so ungefähr ist das so
was
die haben ihr Geld nicht bekommen
nein das kann nicht sein
da weiß ich ja gar nichts von
ich werde das sofort in die Wege
leiten und das ist ja nicht
das entspricht ja überhaupt nicht
unseren Standards
hättet ihr mir doch mal früher
was gesagt, ich wusste da überhaupt nichts von
so, drei Monate später
und wie sieht's aus mit der Kohle
was, das ist immer noch nicht
passiert, ich kann's ja kaum glauben
drei Monate später, nichts passiert
erster Spieler postet auf Twitter
was das für ne Scheißorganisation ist
man, warum postest du sowas
auf Twitter, es gab doch nie
Probleme zwischen uns, ist doch alles cool
was, wie kein Geld, was
kein Geld, da weiß ich ja
gar nichts von, alter
jetzt hab ich doch erklärt, warum
da selten geklagt wird, weil das
oftmals sehr junge Spieler sind, Spieler
die der ganzen Sache komplett ausgeliefert
sind, oftmals Spieler aus dem Ausland
Spieler die eben aus
ihrem Heimatland ja noch hergekommen sind
Teamhouse, sonst was
und nicht von daheim ausspielen
die haben hier, die verstehen kein Deutsch
die verstehen nicht richtig Englisch oftmals
die sind allein in nem fremden Land
und wenn du denen sagst, wir setzen dich vor die Tür
wenn du das Maul aufmachst auf Twitter, da halten die die Klappe
es ist so viel shady business
im E-Sport
im E-Sport-Marketing-Bereich, echter Wahnsinn
super
ja
also
ich mach da echt mal ein Video drüber
ich hab die letzten 13 Jahre
so viel Schwachsinn in der Richtung mitgekriegt
früher
sogar noch ein bisschen mehr
als ich mehr im Gaming-Bereich
kompletter Marketing-Bereich, ja, sag ich ja auch immer
wobei ich da das nicht auf alle ausweiten will
ich hatte auch schon wirklich sehr nette Leute
kompetente Leute aus dem Marketing-Bereich am Start
aber
also früher hab ich ja noch ein bisschen mehr
so Nachrichten bekommen
gerade auch, weil ich viele Gaming-Videos gemacht hab
da hab ich öfters mal Nachrichten bekommen
Max hier
wollen wir zu diesem Thema nicht mal was sagen
wir haben immer noch nicht unsere Preisgelder und sowas
ich hab da meistens nichts großartig zu gemacht
meistens waren es auch oftmals nicht
der Rede wert, aber ich hab auch die ein oder anderen
paar richtigen Hämmer mitbekommen und heute
wie gesagt, gerade vorhin noch eineinhalb Stunden
telefoniert, hab ich auch mal wieder so ein Hammer
mitgekriegt, was wieder gelaufen ist
diesmal im Valorant
Valorant
Valorant, wie spricht man das Game überhaupt
richtig aus?
im Valorant EU-Bereich
wieder
ich hab übrigens das Gefühl, dass
Valorant-Orgs oder Valorant-Teams
die Scheiße noch besonders anziehen
weiß nicht, ob es am Game liegt oder was da los ist
Max hat es dringend erinnert
ich hab ein paar Links offen
wie kommst du darauf? Nun gut
ich würde sagen, lange genug
über deutschen E-Sport gelabert, bzw.
europäischen E-Sport
ja, ich hab's mir auch gerade gedacht, wir gucken uns jetzt mal um
was gibt es denn heute für Smart-Home-Produkte
und
vielleicht finden wir noch irgendwelche Sachen
die sich Tasmota flashen lassen
GitHub, Tasmota, OTA
da haben wir doch
Tasmota
CT, die CT hatte doch so ein Ding
wie heißt denn dieses Repo von der CT
ich will eigentlich nur gucken
hat noch irgendjemand eine Ahnung
wie das Ding hieß?
ja, TuyaConvert, das mein ich
TuyaConvert
gab es dazu irgendwelche Updates in letzter Zeit?
also man kann die meisten Sachen
man kann die meisten Sachen anscheinend
nicht mehr flashen
außer wir finden noch was mit
alter Tuya-Version drauf
der Finanzberatungsbereich
oh ja
die sind auch äußerst seriös
ist, wenn man es mal
genau nimmt, sind diese ganzen
Coaches, kommen in die Gruppe
ist das ja auch sowas in der Richtung
oder
wie, meinst du diese nicht seriös?
ich dachte eigentlich
das ist Top-Notch
die Seriosität
gerade die Typen, die früher immer in dem Auto
kennt ihr noch diese Werbespots
die früher vor Youtube-Videos liefen
die dann mit irgendeinem Ferrari oder so
reingefahren sind und aus dem Fenster
erstmal hier
die Geldscheine
aus dem Fenster gespritzt haben
wie willst du sagen
die sind nicht seriös
das schockiert mich aber jetzt richtig
5000 Euro
passives Einkommen, Leute
ja das gibt es immer noch
aber
fahren die immer noch mit dem Auto vor und spritzen
Geldscheine aus dem Fenster
auf der anderen Seite
ganz ehrlich, Leute
jetzt wenn ich mal wieder den Klassiker
hier lese, Bitconnect
man muss sich überlegen
es gab Leute, die haben allen ernstes
diese Präsentation
gesehen auf Youtube
und haben nachdem sie
die Präsentation gesehen, haben sich gedacht
jawoll
das ist es
da stecke ich mein Geld rein
also es gibt Leute, die sind so drauf
da muss man sich nicht fragen, warum die Leute
gescamt werden
ich
ich meine ernsthaft
würdet ihr nach diesem Intro
denen euer Geld geben
ich meine an Seriosität
kaum noch zu überbieten, oder
hey hey
wasso wasso wasso
also ich würde sagen, da ist die Überweisung
noch schon so gut wie raus
wenn man das sieht
sofort, instant
geht die Überweisung raus
so, aber
Prime Day, jetzt aber, müssen wir langsam mal anfangen
ähm, meine blöde Frage
warum sind die Bilder von Amazon eigentlich so
so ultra schlecht komprimiert
was ist denn das hier
haben sie irgendwie
den Photoshop Typ über Fiverr gekauft
oder was
was ist das für eine Compression von dem Bild
ein bisschen
AWS Kostensparen, oder was
kannst du es ein wenig
größer machen, sehe ich nichts
guck hier, Komprimierung, da
guck dir das an, da oben drum herum
dein PC spackt bei 3
offenen Tabs ab, da würde ich mir mal Gedanken um
einen neuen PC machen, 3 offene Tabs
sollte eigentlich jeder PC, selbst von
2005 oder so packen
warum sind die Bilder so schlecht, eigentlich kann das
Amazon doch
ne, das ist immer noch so schlecht, na gut
vielleicht ist es Client-Side-Compress
was auch immer das sein soll
geht auch um die
Ladezeiten der Seite, ja man kann aber
durchaus gescheite Bilder machen, die
gut aussehen und trotzdem schnell laden
hier haben sie
es doch auch hinbekommen, das ordentlich zu
komprimieren, taugt das
Fire HD 8 Tablet was
meistens, also ich bin mir jetzt
beim aktuellen Fire Tablet nicht sicher
meistens taugen die was, unter
dem, also es gibt 2 Bedingungen
die erfüllt sein müssen
erstens, also es gibt 3
erstens, es ist ordentlich reduziert
wir können uns das gleich mal angucken, also
von 100 auf 50 Euro runter oder sowas
äh zweitens
es gibt eventuell die Möglichkeit
es noch zu
flashen, mit einem Custom ROM
wenn das nicht geht
sollte es noch die Möglichkeit geben
sie zu Deploten
also Beispiel
oder vielleicht auch einen Custom Launcher drauf zu machen
und sowas, dann sind die Dinger gut
allerdings nicht so sehr
als täglich benutzten Tablet
weil dafür sind sie einfach auch zu schwach
und zu nervig und das Display suckt
und das Touchscreen ist nicht gut
für Dashboards sind die zum Beispiel mega nice
also ich hab 2 Fire HD
10 Tablets an der Wand hängen
bei mir im Flur, als Home Assistant
als Heimautomatisierungs-Dashboards
und dafür sind sie extrem nice
und preislich sehr günstig
gewesen
jetzt ist Prime Day, jawoll
wow Angebote
yeah
oh mein Auge
ich muss kurz Dark Theme wieder anschalten
ist es ein GIF?
ein GIF?
was für Smart Home Steckdosen kannst du empfehlen?
aktuell keine
meine sind alle
also ich hab ja noch jede Menge da
aber meine sind noch Flashbar
wenn auch mit teilweise
aufschrauben und anlöten Flashbar
aber ich weiß
nicht welche der aktuellen Angebote
noch Flashbar sind
und viele sind prinzipiell auch gar nicht
mit Tasmota Flashbar
weil sie gar kein ESP32
oder ESP2866
mehr drin haben
haben wir noch Smart Home als Kategorie?
Gaming?
nein haben sie nicht
wow Angebote
das ist halt komplett
tabletisiert
Amazon Geräte im Angebot
Fire HD, ja da haben wir die Dinger doch
ja also das
wie gesagt unter den Voraussetzungen
die ich gerade genannt habe
ist das vielleicht gar nicht übel
aber wie gesagt als täglich benutzten
Tablet würde ich es nicht unbedingt empfehlen
ich bin auch der Meinung
Geräte im Tablet Bereich schön und gut
aber mir persönlich
gefallen
iPads als so täglich
benutzten
Tablet
einfach besser
es ist nicht so dass ich nie einen Android Tablet
hatte, ich hatte sogar mehrere Android Tablets
im Nachhinein
hatte ich sogar richtig viele Android Tablets
ich hatte einen Tegra Note
ich hatte zwei Shield Tablets
ein Lenovo
ein Asus
alles Android Tablets
die zwei Fire HD 10 Tablets
die ich aber absichtlich
dafür gekauft habe
und ganz ehrlich
die stinken ziemlich ab
gegen selbst die Einstiegs
iPads
und die Einstiegs iPads sind gar nicht mal so teuer
für das was man bekommt
also insofern
wenn ich ein Tablet bräuchte zum täglich benutzen
ich persönlich
sehr zu einem iPad tendieren
bei Smartphones sieht das anders aus
Roborock Deals
das können wir uns nachher angucken
wir suchen jetzt mal
Smart Home
in Prime Day
was haben wir da
smarte WLAN Steckdose
misst Stromverbrauchsmesser
das ist typische China Chinesen Überschrift
Smart WLAN Steckdose
misst Stromverbrauchsmesser
Mini Alexa Steckdose mit Sprachsteuerung
Timer Smart Home WLAN Steckdose
funktioniert mit Alexa Google Home
das ist so typische
China Chinesen Bezeichnung von Produkten
so
jetzt das wichtigste was man bei smarten
Steckdosen gleich mal checken muss
ob es sich überhaupt lohnt das zu kaufen
das Motor
nicht möglich weil kein ESP2866
Realtek Chip
Nope
kommt gleich weg
ein Viererpack von Nose
gibt es die noch
Nose
das Motor Steckdose
mit Stromzähler
das Ding ist halt
die selbst Flashbaren
die
sind halt sehr günstig
da bekommst du teilweise
ich guck mal kurz bei mir ins Handy
was ich zuletzt bezahlt hab dafür
es ist aber schon ein bisschen her
wo ich das
wo ich zuletzt welche gekauft habe
Steck
Steckdose
View Order Details
also
hier hab ich
für 40 Euro gekauft
vier Stück
mit
eigentlich richtig gut
ähm
mit das Motor Flashbar
einem normalen Stecker
zwei USB Steckern
man kann auch die USB
getrennt schalten von der eigentlichen Steckdose
und mit Strommessung
das ist so die ultimative
das Motor Steckdose
10 Euro ungefähr das Stück
und das geht teilweise noch günstiger
was in den Bookmarks los ist
das sind Playlists
Musik Playlists
hat die USB
wenn die USB hat ist das preislich
vielleicht sogar ganz interessant
er hat kein USB
ich finde Steckdosen brauchen heutzutage USB
wenn man sowas kauft
ohne USB ist doof
äh die haben kein ESP mehr
die kann man nicht flashen
gehe ich ganz stark davon aus dass die
unflashable sind
alter Amazon
Gosund
ich dachte die haben sich jetzt nach Corona
in Gesund umbenannt
die kann man
ich glaube nicht dass man die flashen kann
ich glaube da ist
diese Meros Dinge haben kein ESP
mehr drin
ok
gehe ich nicht von aus
das Motor Steckdose, ah guck mal
Curry Smart Meter
Meros kannst du über
HA bei LAN Only nutzen
tatsächlich
auch LAN Only zum Setup
oder braucht man dafür App
auf dem Smartphone und China Chinesen
Account
weil es gibt immer zwei Schritte
ist sie wirklich komplett Offline nutzbar
auch inklusive Initial im Addon
ja aber wie bekommst du sie
ins WLAN zum Beispiel
du musst sie erstmal ins WLAN
bekommen
geht das irgendwie Offline
oder braucht man initial die App
also der beste Fall ist natürlich man braucht nie
die China Chinesen App
der zweitbeste Fall ist man braucht
nur zum Setup die China Chinesen App
so hier haben wir das
Curry Meter
zwei Stück
vermute ich jetzt einfach mal das es zwei Stück sind oder
sind es zwei Stück
ne eine
Farbe
alter was ist mit den China Chinesen
wieder los
Gesamtanzahl der Steckdosen eins
Farbe zwei Stücke
was haben wir hier
vier Stücke
eine Stücke
ähm
wenn die sich
also da ist das Motor schon vorinstalliert
ich würde es trotzdem nochmal selbst flashen
gar nicht so
übel haben die USB
sieht man da irgendwas von
ne auch kein USB ja das ist doof
ich finde so
Zwischenstecker sollten USB haben
am besten zwei USB Anschlüsse
weil mittlerweile hat man so viel USB Gerät
es ist einfach enorm praktisch
USB zu haben zum Beispiel
du kannst nur so ein Ding hängen
willst aber vielleicht ein Bluetooth Proxy
ESP32 hinhängen
brauchst ein USB
also USB ist einfach immer
ich sag nicht das man nicht auch die einen oder anderen ohne USB
nehmen kann aber defaultmäßig
ist es nice wenn man
so Zwischenstecker hat die noch zusätzlich
USB bieten
aber das liest sich preis-leistungsmäßig gar nicht mal so übel
zwölf Euro das Stück
kommt preflasht
ich würde danach trotzdem nochmal selbst flashen
wer weiß was für einen China-Chinesen
Tasmota da drauf geflasht wurde
was das CurrySmartMeter
so genau macht
CurrySmarter
CurrySmarter ist der
Name des Herstellers in Anführungszeichen
das ist natürlich nicht der Hersteller
das sind alles irgendwelche Thuja
Dosen ursprünglich mal gewesen
CurrySmartMeter
CurrySmarter
den gehen die Namen
auch echt nicht aus
der ShellyPlug
ja der ShellyPlug hat aber auch kein USB
was ein bisschen doof ist
der ShellyPlug ist aber schön klein
allein schon aus dem Gesichtspunkt
finde ich den ShellyPlug eigentlich ganz nice
hier den da
also allein schon mal der relativ klein ist
der ShellyPlug ist aber wahrscheinlich
auch irgendein China-Chinesen Ding
unter der Haube
RWX Wesker am Start
Dankeschön für den Sub
und für eventuell andere Prime Subs
die ich übersehen hab
Triton95
nice, hab ich überhaupt nicht gesehen, bist du noch am Start?
hat er was geschrieben, hab ich überhaupt nicht gesehen
seit über 10 Jahren schaue ich deine Videos
Battlefield, BadCompany, 2 Beste
da gebührt dir definitiv der Prime Sub
ja nice
das ist extrem
und der
NateMan ist auch am Start
danke für den Sub
hab ich total übersehen
Shelly ist aus Bulgarien
das Gerät selber
muss nicht in Bulgarien
hergestellt worden sein und da geh ich auch mal stark von aus
also
es gibt offensichtliche Shelly Produkte
die China-Chinesen Zeug sind
ja, zum Beispiel das
das neue Heizungsthermostat
Moment, nee, das bringt mich sogar
durcheinander, nicht das Shelly
Heizungsthermostat, sorry
das mein ich gar nicht
wir hatten letztens noch ein Heizungsthermostat
rausgebracht, wo ich gesagt hab
oh, das ist ein billig China-Chinesen Ding
das mein ich gar nicht
Akara, ja genau
ja, das Akara Thermostat
ja, das mein ich genau
dieses Ding gibt es
seit 2-3 Jahren schon
unter allen möglichen Namen
Akara ist ja auch Xiaomi und Xiaomi ist
China-Chinesen Zeug, aber
das ist halt übelster Müll, ich hab davon auch
eins hier, fand ich richtig
krottig
dann hab ich's grad verwechselt, ja
aber trotzdem geh ich davon aus, dass Shelly
die Dinger nicht selbst herstellt
Change my mind
Arzi, danke schön für den Sub
23 Monate
Excellent, warum ist das
Smart Home? iWatch
nein, das ist
nicht zufällig ähnlich
benannt wie Apple-Geräte
kann überhaupt nicht sein, iWatch
Series 8, nein, das soll
keine Nähe zu Apple-Produkten
irgendwie darstellen oder so, die es nicht hat
rein Zufall
reiner Zufall
TP-Link, Tapo
TP-Link hat sich das letzte Jahr
über nicht mit Ruhm bekleckert, was ihre
Smart Home-Geschichten angeht
indem sie einfach ihre Offline-API
abgestellt haben mit einem Firmware-Update
die sind dann wieder zurückgerudert
glaub mittlerweile geht's
über Umwege wieder
aber da haben die bei mir alles
da verspielt, dass ich mir das jemals gekauft hätte
WLAN steckt
haben die
USB
auch nicht, oder?
kein USB
es scheint wenige
zu geben mit
Moment, ich suche ja auch das falsche
nach Smart Home wollte ich eigentlich suchen
smarte WLAN-Steckdose
so, was haben wir denn sonst noch?
Super LED-WiFi-Sternenhimmel-Projektor
wer braucht denn
sowas?
für Kinderzimmer vielleicht?
ja, da freuen sie sich
naja, gut
wie, das ist das einzige
Smart Home, was er findet bei Prime Day
also man muss ehrlich sagen, so die
Amazon-Kategorien
und sowas ist echt schon
ein bisschen Fail, ja?
wie würde
man das denn richtig offiziell
jetzt machen bei Amazon?
gibt es hier sowas wie Kategorie?
Kategorie?
wo ist das überhaupt?
alle Kategorien
wo könnte Smart Home
darunter sein? Elektronik und
Computer oder
eher Haushalt
und sowas
Möbel, Haushalt, hier Elektronik, Computer
wo ist eher Smart Home darunter?
also die Amazon-Suche ist wirklich
an Pegahaftigkeit
kaum zu überbieten
aber insofern können wir ja auch suchen
so, was haben wir denn sonst noch hier schönes?
Smart LED
die sind bestimmt
viel kleiner als sie aussehen
und sie sind
also die haben ja auch, guck mal, die haben ja quasi
gar keine Zonen richtig
das ist ja Müll
dafür billig
funktioniert mit tollen Effekten
naja
nee, das ist ja nur einfarbig
ne, das ist ja nix
nee
Nano Leafs kannst du wenigstens ordentlich beleuchten
Greta Ross, danke schön
für den Sub
das ist ja nur ein, aber
da hat man wenigstens fetzige Lichteffekte
im Kinderzimmer
wie hieß dieses Ding nochmal mit dieser
mit diesem Shoppingkanal
genau, der Fanatic
Headshot Controller Pro
und mit
fetzigen Lichteffekten sind sie bei der
nächsten Gaming Session der King
falls sich noch jemand daran erinnert
das ist so alt
hast du eigentlich Ambilight hinter dem TV
ja, aber
kein Ambilight was der Fernseher mitbringt
Zertifiziert für Menschen
oh, das ist aber nett von denen
das ist ein Amazon Smart Plug
Moment, Moment
ist das so eine Art
Amazon Basics oder wie
die, die, die
Amazon Basics Smart Plug
Zertifiziert für Menschen
die sind äußerst zu vorkommend
muss ich sagen
falls ihr es nicht kennt
geht nur eine Minute
wer in Computerspielen die Nase vorn haben will
braucht eine Top Ausstattung
und da ist der
Fanatic Headshot Controller genau das Richtige
das Set besteht aus einer
ultra präzisen
dieses Kabel
diesen Gamer Maus
und einem Highspeed Pad
zusammen ein unschlagbares Team
die Maus ist super ergonomisch und lässt
sich an jede Handform anpassen
das sorgt auch in langen Gamer Sessions
für ermüdungsfreies Spielen
6 Maus Buttons und ein 5 Wege Steuerrad
sorgen dafür, dass sie ihre
Spielfigur auch in heißen Gefechten
im Griff haben. Die Plasma
Gleit Maus Füße sorgen zusammen mit dem
Highspeed Pad für minimale Haft
und Gleitreibung für schnelles, präzises
Zielen im Spiel
Das Ding sieht so krass
guck mal, das sieht so krass
unergonomisch aus
dieses Ding
Das leichte Kabel kommt Ihnen dabei garantiert nicht
in die Quere, dafür sorgt die
clevere Kabelführung
Fetzige Leuchteffekte mit unterschiedlichen Farben
Helligkeit und Pulsfrequenz
machen das Spiel noch rasanter
Profi Gamer sind begeistert von den
Programmiermöglichkeiten für Maus und
Tastatur, selbst während des Spiels
Auch Makros lassen sich
problemlos einsetzen, damit
sind sie bei Flugsimulationen, Rennspielen
und anderen Games der King
Der Fanatic Headshot Controller
ist das ultimative Set
für Gamer und
wetten, dass er auch als Geschenk gut ankommt?
Probieren Sie es aus
Es gab also früher
auch schon Schwachsinn in der Richtung, was Gaming
Equipment angeht
Ist gekauft, ich vermute mal, das Ding gibt es
überhaupt nicht mehr
Moment, der hat ein Video damit gemacht?
Wirklich?
Was ein Schrott
Jetzt geht es wieder nicht mehr
USB-Gerät wurde nicht erkannt
Ja, ihr hört es vielleicht im Hintergrund die ganze Zeit
Das kürzlich angeschlossene Gerät hat
veraltete Treiber
Ja, aber es ging doch gerade, warum geht er denn jetzt nicht mehr?
Guck mal, wie das geschrieben ist
Habt ihr es gesehen, wie der Name geschrieben ist?
Cringe
Okay, was haben wir
sonst noch Schönes im Smart Home Bereich anzubieten?
Bosch
Smart Home Raumthermostat
Nö
Smart Air Quality Monitor
Die Dinger
sacken leider
Ich habe mir ja auch
von Ikea so ein Ding geholt
So einen Air Quality
Monitorer
Es ist nicht gut
gewesen
Es ist laufend
verstaubt
Sodass es nicht mehr richtig
gemessen hat, also es war keine gute Konstruktion
Weiß nicht, ob das Ding hier besser ist
Zumal das Ikea Ding an sich
einen ganz guten Sensor drin hat
Aber es funktioniert halt dauerhaft nicht
Und wenn ich das
einmal in der Woche aufschrauben muss und durchpusten
dann habe ich keinen Bock drauf
Ich kann im Stream eh nichts
kaufen, weil ich nicht eingeloggt bin
Wenn schon lege ich mir was in den Warenkopf
fürs nächste Mal oder fürs Bestellen
Äh, braucht keiner
Was ist das hier?
Milf
Milfra
Auch sehr guter Name
Moment, 4 Stück für 20 Euro?
Was ist denn das?
Das ist sehr günstig
Aber wahrscheinlich ist es Schrott
Hä, warum schlafen da die Leute
dann immer?
Ich würde lieber so in der China Chinesen stecken
Sogar USB
Gute Kombination, Leute
Und wenn es sich jetzt noch flashen lässt
Euer festes Material
Si
Silik
Kagel
Silikagel
Meinen die Silikongel?
Ist das ein richtiges Wort, Leute?
Silikagel, gibt es das?
Gibt es das wirklich?
Aha
Kann man es flashen?
Wenn man es flashen kann, ist das preislich
gar nicht schlecht
Tasmota
Tut mir leid
Da müssen sie den Hersteller
Dieses Amazon-Fragensystem
ist einfach so
unglaublicher Fail
Danke, Hauke, ja
Aber wisst ihr, Hauke kann da gar nichts für
Amazon hat Hauke
so eine komische E-Mail geschickt
Können sie diese Frage vielleicht beantworten?
Und da hat Hauke einfach, weil er nett ist, drauf geantwortet
Da müssen sie den Hersteller
fragen, die Leute checken es halt wieder nicht
Das wäre eine Frage
an den Hersteller, ja, nice, Stefan
Läuft mit Tasmota
Sehr erfreulich, dass diese günstigen...
Hmm
Das ist aber von 2021
Ich bezweifle, dass die Steckdosen, die
2021 ausgeliefert werden, immer noch
mit Tasmota
gehen
Ehrlich gesagt glaube ich das nicht, dass die noch mit
Tasmota gehen
Es wäre, es ist aber wirklich sehr
günstig, sollten die gehen mit Tasmota
Du hast einen USB-Anschluss?
Kannst du Remote schalten?
Gut, Strom messen tun sie wahrscheinlich
nicht
Kaufen und im nächsten Stream testen, sonst
Retour
Normalerweise würde ich das machen, aber ich habe noch so
viele schaltbare Steckdosen
Ich habe da eigentlich überhaupt keinen Bedarf
Mach es für die Science
Ja, ich meine, okay
Es sind ja nur
19 Euro
Dann habe ich wenigstens auch eine Steckdose
von Milfra
Bester Name
Ich trau den Dingern aber nicht
Die sehen schon echt billig aus
Milfra
Okay, scheiß drauf, ich bestell
mir einen Pack jetzt
Place your order
Okay
Ich habe ein Packen bestellt gerade
Milfra
Arriving Saturday
Na dann
Hast du den Coupon benutzt?
Oh
Äh, ja
Es hat nur 19 Euro gekostet
Moment
Oder wäre das nochmal billiger?
Ne, ne
Ob ich das anklicke
Ob ich das anklicke oder nicht, ist egal
Kostet beides 19 Euro
Ich muss da nichts canceln
Es kostet 19 Euro, was ich bestellt habe
Also es ist richtig so
Und ich habe es jetzt
nochmal in den Warenkorb gelegt, mit dem Voucher
angeklickt
Jetzt kostet es auch 19 Euro, das hat es schon automatisch
gemacht
Ja, ich war im Checkout, Leute
Alles gut
Hat funktioniert
Was?
Jetzt ernsthaft?
Ich habe es eben gerade nochmal
ausgecheckt, da war nichts
mit 9,99 Euro, jetzt
verbietet mich da, oder?
Voucher applied to one item
So, und jetzt sage ich
Add to basket
Ja
Proceed to
Checkout
Ah
Ha
Chatge, ihr habt recht
Ha, okay, ich habe es jetzt auch
gesehen gerade, okay
Also, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja
Ihr habt recht, bye
Okay, das ist schon enorm günstig
für 9 Euro
Ich cancel die andere Order
jetzt einfach
So, nice
Jetzt habe ich vier Steckdosen bestellt
für 9,99 Euro
Also Leute, wenn die sich
das Motor flashen lassen, ist das
der geilste Deal ever
Oder mein Haus
brennt ab dadurch
Ich trau mich wahrscheinlich nicht
die Dinger zu verwenden am Ende
Warum haben die auf einmal
9,99 Bewertung eben, hatten die doch
viel weniger
Ach nee, Moment, nur wenn ich nach
das Motor such, hatten die weniger
Ich bin mal gespannt, ob das noch geht
Ich glaube nicht, dass es noch
funktioniert
Aber 9 Euro für, also wir
probieren das, sind die CE zertifiziert
Da ist bestimmt ein CE-Zeichen drauf
Aber
da kannst du halt nichts drauf geben, das
drucken die sich im Zweifelsfall auch
Ja, guck da hier, das drucken die sich im Zweifelsfall
auch einfach selbst drauf, die China-Kinder
Das juckt die überhaupt nicht
Also wir können zwei Varianten probieren, um die zu flashen
Entweder OTA, das wäre
natürlich richtig, Jackpot
Oder wir können sogar
probieren, die aufzumachen und
zum Flashen was dran zu löten
Gibt's dann wieder
Einen Flash-Stream
Mal gucken
Messen die auch den Stromverbrauch?
Wahrscheinlich nicht, weil das
wäre jetzt echt zu krass noch
Ich meine, so richtig genau
sind die Dinger eh nicht, aber das macht nichts
Die sind meistens genau genug
Ja, nicht schlecht
European-Konform CE
Okay, lass uns
mal kurz vergleichen
Ob das das China-CE-Zeichen
ist, oder das echte
richtige Zeichen
Okay
Komperge
Das ist das
China-Export-CE-Zeichen, oder?
China-Chinesen-Fake-CE-Zeichen
Würde ich jetzt mal vermuten
Die sind zu nah aneinander dran, oder?
Ist es das richtige?
Das erkennt man ja kaum
Soll ich das jetzt gescheit machen?
Ich glaub, ich muss das
Ich glaub
Ne, das könnte tatsächlich
das richtige sein, guck mal
Vom Abstand her
ist das eher das richtige
Aber ganz davon abgesehen
ist es eh egal, die können sich da draufdrucken
was sie wollen, die China-Chinesen
Wie ist das eigentlich um den Datenschutz
bei Alexa-Geräten bestellt?
Das musst du Amazon fragen
Also ich benutze keine
Voice-Assistance
Aus unter anderem dem Grund, weil du immer
ein Mikrofon hast, was permanent mithören könnte
Aber das
muss jeder selbst wissen
Goofy
Was soll das sein?
RGB
Wie nennt man das?
Ein
RGB
Säule
Aber eigentlich ganz nett, oder?
RGB-Stehlampe
Kann man das
ordentlich in
Home Assistant einbauen?
Kompat-Verbindung
Ah, WiFi plus BLE
Oh, das ist nice
Das heißt, ich brauche die offizielle
App gar nicht
Welche ist das hier jetzt?
Mit Home Assistant geht es nicht
Goofy
Goofy Bluetooth
Bluetooth
Thermometer, ne, das geht
anscheinend
nicht
Das ist die Frage
Das ist die Frage, welches
davon geht
Hier
Ich will das nicht mit der App verbinden
Ich will das in
Home Assistant einbinden
Goofy
Das ist wieder so ein Ding
wo du erst mal
China-Kinesen-Registration
Nettigkeit des Herstellers, das auch lokal verwendet. Oh ne, ne, ne, ne.
Außerdem wird die Integration nicht mehr supported.
Ne, ne, ne, ne, ne. Da verlasse ich mich nicht drauf.
Ne, das fällt flach für mich.
Uwi.
Welche Klimaanlage hast du? Eine von Mitsubishi Heavy. Ich kann dir den genauen, den genauen nicht, nicht sagen.
Warum sind die Bosch Dinger so ultra teuer?
Kannst die auch auf dem Shelly kaufen für 15 Euro.
Kein Wunder, dass den Kram keiner kaufen will. Wie viel kostet das normal?
74 Euro, die sind halt immer ganz dicht.
Ist deine Klimaanlage in Home Assistant drin?
Ja und nein. Ich hab sie immer eingebunden über so eine Infrarot-Steuerung, aber nie wirklich benutzt.
Ich mach das immer über die Fernbedienung.
Da gibt's Bosch Smart Home, who cares, alter. Niemand interessiert sich für Bosch Smart Home.
Heizungsthermostat für 45 Euro, das könnte ganz gut sein unter der Voraussetzung, es ist Bluetooth oder irgendwie Low Energy und sonst was und lässt sich einbinden in Home Assistant.
Über was betreibt man das? 230 Volt? Das wäre aber ein ziemliches Hardcore-Thermostate.
Über was läuft das denn? ZigBee? WiFi? Wahrscheinlich ZigBee, oder?
Ist das Home Assistant? ZigBee. Es ist ein proprietärer Funkstandard, na geil.
ZigBee to MQTT, ja wie jetzt? Hä? Ja ist das jetzt ZigBee oder ist es nicht ZigBee?
Ist es das? Gucken wir mal. BTHRA, gucken wir gleich mal.
Kein sinnvoller Betrieb ohne Kontrolle, denn das Koppeln per ZigBee direkt mit dem Echo hat definitiv nicht funktioniert.
ZigBee aber nicht kompatibel.
Manche schreiben, dass es geht und manche nicht.
Zwei, ja das wird's wahrscheinlich sein.
Haben wir da irgendeinen Produktname von?
Ne, passende Bridge will ich nicht.
Gebrauchs- und Benutzerhandbuch.
Wie nennt sich das Ding? Hut? Was? Hut? WiFi? King? What?
Okay. Thermostat 2, Kurzanleitung.
Ja, das scheint zu laufen.
ZigBee to MQTT, Bosch MTHRA.
Okay, das ist ein bisschen komplizierter.
Wie lange halten die Batterien davon? Ich bin echt geneigt dazu, das mal auszuprobieren.
Wie oft? Die Leute sind schon pp-iger, oder?
Können auch Akkus anstatt normaler Batterien verwendet werden?
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Es müssen keine Akkus sein, wir verwenden auch Batterien.
Das ist legit exakt das Gegenteil von dem, was er wissen wollte.
Zwei Monate ohne Wechsel. Ich erwarte, dass sowas mal mindestens eineinhalb Jahre hält mit den Batterien.
Sonst ist es doch für'n Arsch.
Wisst ihr was? Oh, oh, was war denn das für'n Bild? Habt ihr das gerade gesehen?
Das sah ziemlich broken aus. What the fuck?
Und wie lange halten die Batterien? Wisst ihr was? Komm, scheiß drauf.
Ich bestell das jetzt und dann probieren wir einfach auch gleich noch im Stream aus, ob das funktioniert.
Hab ich ein bisschen was zu basteln wieder.
Wait a minute. Nicht mehr lieferbar? Ach nee. Ich hab mich verguckt. Ist doch noch lieferbar.
Nee, jetzt doch nicht. Ja, was denn jetzt? Amazon, please.
Please. Okay, jetzt hat's funktioniert. So. Mal geordert.
Acara FP2. Oh, wenn es den gibt. Ist das die Presence Detection Geschichte? Acara FP2?
Oh, nice. Ja, POG. Der wird direkt gebuyed. Direkt reingecashed.
Proceed to checkout. Bam. Lieferbar Friday. Bam. Bestellung ist raus.
Also hab ich heute schonmal, was haben wir denn jetzt ausgegeben? 70, 45 und 10 Euro.
Okay, 150 Euro sind schonmal, naja, 120 Euro sind schonmal weg. Ja. Let's go.
Hat sich doch schonmal gelohnt jetzt. Wenn die Dinger was taugen.
Ich mein, es kann auch sein, dass es einfach Müll ist und ich es direkt wieder zurückschicke.
Aber ein bisschen Smart Home basteln schadet ja nicht, ne?
Was ist denn ein guter Zigbee Stick? Ich hab einen. Ich frag nur, weil es gibt jetzt ja neue mittlerweile.
So mit neuerem Protokoll. Oder kauft man gar keinen Zigbee Stick mehr und kauft sich jetzt einen Thread-kompatiblen Zigbee Stick?
Der Bosch Smart Home Zeug muss anscheinend echt weg, oder? Die brauchen anscheinend Lagerplatz.
Ich hab einen Konbi 2, aber es gibt jetzt eine etwas neuere Generation als den Konbi 2.
Konbi 2 vs. Sonoff, ja zum Beispiel.
Gibt es da heute vielleicht was? Aha.
Sind das die guten? Weil, die Konbis kosten aber auch viel.
Konbi Dongle Plus. Die heißen alle so.
Modell? Was ist denn da der Unterschied? Minus P?
Das ist ja jetzt die China-Chinesen-Bezeichnung wieder. Man weiß wieder nicht, was man benutzt.
Was ist denn die Differenz dazwischen?
Oh shit, was ist denn der Unterschied zwischen Minus E und Minus P?
Äh, P. AnyCC2652.
Okay, nice. Ich hab wirklich keine Ahnung, was da vorne ist.
Wir haben den da, den da. Was ist denn da der Unterschied dazwischen?
Und den da. What the fuck?
Das ist CC265P. Okay, das ist ein älterer Ding. Der suckt anscheinend.
Und das ist ein neuer. Der kostet aber 39. Ach, das sind zwei.
Achso. Wisst ihr was? Ich bestell mir auch mal so einen Dongle hier.
Da haben wir nämlich noch einen weiteren Zigbee-Stick, wo wir ein bisschen basteln können im Stream.
Das ist nicht verkehrt. Geld muss weg.
Jetzt ist Amazon gerade down oder sowas.
So, jetzt geht's.
Okay, hier gibt's eine Erklärung, zu was der Unterschied ist.
P versus E Dongle.
Nee, wir hatten die Frage F oder...
Nee, nee, nee, Moment, Moment. Unsere Frage war, was der Unterschied ist zwischen...
Welcher war das hier jetzt? Modell?
P zwischen P und E.
Achso, ja, im Prinzip genau das.
Also P ist der Gute, P ist der Gute, E ist der Alte, oder?
Guck mal, die können sogar Thread.
Ach, das hier ist der Neuere, oder wie?
Das heißt, der ist ein bisschen neuer.
Nee, Moment, das ist...
Ich glaub, das ist das Falsche.
Okay, der ist...
Naja, ist scheiß drauf. Ich hab den jetzt...
Okay, der hier ist... Der E ist sogar ein bisschen neuer.
Obwohl der billiger ist?
Jetzt blick ich schnell mal durch, Leute.
Moment, der kann aber weniger.
Wait a minute. Wie, der kann weniger?
Nee, das ist doch...
Egal, scheiß drauf. Für unsere Testkiste ist das eh wurscht.
Wir testen das, dann mach ich ein Raspberry Pi, hau Home Assistant drauf, wir probieren's aus.
Der Rest ist doch eigentlich egal für uns jetzt zum Ausprobieren.
Heute hab ich echt tatsächlich mal zur Abwechslung relativ viel Geld beim Prime Day ausgegeben bis jetzt.
Und die letzten Jahre hab ich so gut wie nix ausgegeben, weil nur Shit dabei war.
Ja, Coupon, 5% oder so waren das.
Was ist denn das, ne Wetterstation?
Ja, da hab ich schon eigentlich...
Ich hab ne China-Chinesen-Wetterstation bei mir am Stall hängen.
Die hat zwei Akkus, also zwei Akkubatterien, also Akkus in Batterienformen drinnen.
Die laden sich selbst auf, sehr praktisch, geht nicht leer.
Was hast du bis jetzt gekauft?
Ich habe gekauft ein Zigbee-Stick, der auch Thread und alles mögliche kann.
Ein Acara-Presence-Detection-Sensor, ein Thermostat für die Heizung
und einen 4er-Pack smarte Steckdosen, wo ich hoffe, dass man die flashen kann.
Das wär der Deal des Jahres so für 9 Euro, 4 Steckdosen.
Die fackeln bestimmt mein Haus ab, die sind zu billig.
Okay, ich glaube, jetzt sind wir durch mit den sinnvollen Sachen, was Smart Home angeht.
Jetzt kommt nur noch unbedeutender Shit, der mich nicht interessiert.
Was ist denn das?
Türschloss-Finger... Alter, was?
Das sollten sie mal dem Lockpicking-Lawyer geben.
Der hat das wahrscheinlich in zwei Sekunden auf.
Was hat ein Roborock schönes?
Roborock Prime Day, Prime Sale, jetzt kaufen, jawohl.
Roborock S8 Ultra.
Oh, so günstig.
Ich finde die Taktik eigentlich ganz cool.
Mit diesem automatisch Entleerenden.
Der Kram ist teuer.
Das wäre gar nicht so sehr das Problem.
Ich könnte mir das durchaus vorstellen, so viel Geld auszugeben,
wenn es einfach einmal im Monat muss man was machen, der Rest ist egal.
Aber was mich persönlich daran nervt ist,
dass das nur mit dauerhaftem Netzwerk und Internetzugang geht
und nur über die offizielle China-Chinesen-App.
Das schreckt mich bei Staubsauger-Robotern ab.
Schon was bestellt, ja.
Vier Sachen.
Okay, da gucken wir nochmal was anderes.
Lass uns mal gerade schauen.
Oh, guck mal.
Pro-Gamer-Zahnbürste am Start.
Black Edition.
Kennt ihr noch mein Video?
Wo ich die Pro-Gamer-Zahnbürste...
Beste Handy-Kamera-Arbeit.
Wo ich es jetzt nicht aufkriege.
Da kann man per Bluetooth koppeln und dann hat man so ein komisches Ding dabei,
was traurig ist, wenn man nicht genug geputzt hat.
Es gibt doch Vale Tudo und da sind auch die Roborocks dabei.
Ja, aber nicht die allerneuesten, oder?
Weil man die nicht mal gescheit routen kann.
Der Hüpfer. Der war schon lange nicht mal hier, der Hüpfer.
Gibt's den überhaupt auf Twitch noch?
Routing requires full disassembly.
Ja, vergiss es halt. Sucked.
Da hab ich keinen Bock drauf.
Das mach ich nicht. Full disassembly mach ich nicht.
Ganz ernsthaft, ich hab mir mal ein Video dazu angeguckt.
Ohne Scheiß, da blickst du nicht durch.
Da hab ich keinen Bock drauf, um das zu routen.
Welche Kategorie führen wir uns jetzt nochmal kurz zu Gemüte?
Irgendwas, was mich direkt da anspricht.
Die offizielle Nintendo Switch Micro SD.
Oder wie offiziell die ist, weiß ich nicht.
Wahrscheinlich haben sie mit Nintendo irgendeinen Deal.
Externe Speicher.
Ich mein, SSDs kann man nie genug haben.
Ihr kennt mich. SSDs gehen immer.
Ah, guck mal. Meine SSD gibt es dort.
Also exakt meine. Das ist original.
Die haben sie geklaut bei mir aus dem Rechner und verkaufen sie jetzt bei Amazon.
Nicht genug M2 Ports.
Ich hab noch zwei, glaube ich, auf Mainboard.
Aber ich hab keinen Bock, mein Mainboard oder mein Rechner aufzumachen.
Ich hab auch genug Speicher.
Ich mein, guck mal. Das reicht.
Eins, zwei, drei, vier SSDs mit jeweils zwei Terabyte.
Das ist halt die Schrottigste SSD von allen.
Auf der ist halt nichts drauf.
Und noch eine Magnetplatte.
Auf der sehr viel drauf ist zum aktuellen Zeitpunkt.
Was haben wir denn hier? Wi-Fi und Netzwerklösungen.
Ritzbox.
Warum ist da eine Steckdose am Start?
Warum sehe ich da eine Steckdose? Was hat das eine mit dem anderen zu tun?
Netge Repeater Wi-Fi.
Äh, warum hat das Ding eine Steckdose?
Ach, das kann man so als Zwischenstecker benutzen oder wie?
Ne, das benutzt man als Zwischenstecker, dass man die Steckdose...
Das ist ein Repeater. Ich steck den in die Steckdose und kann die Steckdose halt noch weiter benutzen.
Ja, eigentlich keine doofe Idee.
Welche Steckdose hast du geholt?
Milfra. Geiler Name, oder?
Aber ich würde die nicht kaufen, ehrlich gesagt.
Die waren so billig, dass sie schon fast gefährlich sind wahrscheinlich.
Neun Euro für vier Steckdosen und angeblich kann man sie sogar flashen.
Ja, Milfra heißen die.
Geiler Name, ne?
Willst das nicht suchen? Ja, verstehe ich.
Ey, den Switch, ne? Genau den da.
Den verkaufen die doch auch schon seit 20 Jahren.
Oder so in dem Dreh.
Lass mal gucken. Kann man Amazon-Bewertungen sortieren nach Age?
Neueste zuerst. Alter, was...
Kann man die ordentlich sortieren?
Neueste. Neueste sucken halt. Ich will die Neueste wissen.
Soll ich jetzt fünfmal auf Weiter drücken, oder was?
Page Number. Page Number 100.
Page Number 1000.
Geht nicht mehr.
Die gibt es schon ewig.
Ja, wie lang der Artikel drin ist, ist ja egal.
Den können die auch immer wieder neu einstellen.
Wir gucken mal bei Guides.
Release Date. Das gibt es doch schon ewig, das Ding, Alter.
Gibt es irgendwie seit 20 Jahren oder so.
Oder zumindest ein ähnlicher.
Ja. Okay, seit...
Seit 10 Jahren gibt es den. Alles klar.
Seit 10 Jahren bei Amazon gelistet.
Vielleicht gibt es den dann noch länger.
Nicht, dass ich mir den kaufen will.
Das Ding, da bin ich nur so oft schon drüber gestolpert.
Das hat auch ein USB-Out. Ja, die Dinger sind eigentlich
auf dem Papier richtig nice.
Welche Smart-Steckdose kannst du für ein Balkon-Kraftwerk empfehlen?
Weiß nicht, was sich da anbietet.
Vielleicht irgendwas mit
so Verbrauchsmessung oder so.
Wobei es ja nicht wirklich Verbrauch ist, sondern das Gegenteil.
Ob die das dann auch messen können? Weiß ich nicht.
Was spricht dagegen, einfach ganz ohne smarte Steckdose
das anzuschließen? Einfach in die Wand?
Du willst es doch eh nicht abmachen, oder?
Willst du es zwischendurch abmachen?
Ich hätte jetzt halt gedacht, das bleibt halt dran.
Ja, mag das egal sein.
Aber, ob man es von der Steckdose abfragen kann,
ist die andere Frage.
Oder meinst du, das Ding zeigt dann einfach an,
so und so viel Verbrauch und in Wirklichkeit ist es kein Verbrauch,
sondern, ja, generated.
Kofax, danke für den Sub.
Nee, dann würde da nicht Minus dastehen, sondern es würde einfach...
Ja, okay, das kann durchaus sein.
Wie gesagt, damit kenne ich mich nicht so wahnsinnig aus.
Aber, wenn ich den Player richtig verstanden habe,
sieht das gar keinen Unterschied.
Das weiß ich aber nicht, ob es wirklich so ist.
Ich habe da keine Ahnung von.
Da kann ich dir aber immer noch keine empfehlen,
weil die, die ich mir gekauft habe,
die unter anderem halt auch den Verbrauch messen können
und gar nicht mal so ungenau sind, wenn man die kalibriert hat,
die gibt es halt nicht mehr
oder lassen sich wahrscheinlich nicht mehr flashen.
Kann nicht jede smarte Steckdose.
Ja, Verlauf muss die Steckdose nicht können.
Verlauf machst du dann dort, wo du die Daten abfragst.
Home Assistant hat übrigens mittlerweile eine richtig schicke Anzeige
für sowas mit...
Wenn du mehrere Geräte hast, die den Stromverbrauch messen können,
kannst du dir... kannst du dir sogar anzeigen lassen,
so nach dem Motto, okay, ich ziehe gerade alles komplett
aus meinem... aus meiner eigenen Herstellung quasi.
Oder ich, ja...
Das ist nice.
Was habt ihr von Fritz, die... die... die smarten...
die smarte Steckdose? Wusste ich gar nicht, dass die eine haben.
Die Fritzdinger sind tatsächlich ganz okay.
Das Coole an denen ist, dass sie über Deckt funktionieren
und dementsprechend quasi...
direkt mit der Fritzbox kommunizieren können
über Spezial Oldschool
Home Telefon Protokoll.
Das ist aber ganz gut, weil das ist ziemlich energiesparend.
Dafür ist das Problem bei den Fritz-Thermostaten,
dass die sich nur alle 10 Minuten oder so updaten.
Das heißt, da hast du manchmal ein bisschen Verzögerung drin.
Stört mich jetzt nicht, aber wenn es ein Kriterium ist,
dann taugt das nix dafür.
Richtig, genau, ja.
Die alten PS3 konnte man früher flashen.
Ja, ich würde sogar sagen, man kann viele...
man kann die immer noch flashen, wenn man will.
Und meint davon, was zu haben.
Dein Handy solltest du doch nicht speichern.
Du brauchst doch gar keine App für.
Du brauchst irgendeine Smart-Home-Zentrale,
in die du das einbindest und die hat ja auch eine Datenbank
und kann Langzeit-History speichern.
Kannst sowas wie Home Assistant verwenden zum Beispiel.
Oder OpenHub, wenn du eher auf Java-Geschichten stehst.
Oder IO-Broker,
was in Deutschland recht beliebt ist.
Solche Dinger.
Ich würde es mit meiner alten Firmware gehen.
Weil ich habe meine PS3 glaube ich schon 4-5 Jahre
oder so nicht mehr angehabt.
Okay, ich habe noch eine alte, fette...
Ja, wie gesagt, ganz ehrlich,
ich würde die Dinger eh in irgendeine Smart-Home-Zentrale einbinden.
So ist das doch alles gefuddelt.
Da musst du dir irgendwie IPs von deinen Steckdosen merken
und sowas. Sag doch.
Irgendwelche Prime-Deals. Ne, ich will dir das noch nicht empfehlen.
Was heißt noch nicht? Morgen gibt es das dann nicht mehr.
Ich habe eine Vierer-Pack-Steckdosen gekauft,
die man angeblich noch flashen kann
und die sogar USB-Output haben.
Smarte Steckdosen für 9 Euro Vierer-Pack.
Ja, also...
Oder sagen wir mal 10 Euro Vierer-Pack,
da kostet eine Steckdose, eine smarte Steckdose 2,50 Euro.
Also entweder wollen die das Lager leeren
oder mein Haus brennt ab, sobald ich das in die Steckdose stecke.
Hast du den Link zu den Steckdosen?
Ja, Moment. Falls wir sie nicht sogar schon aufhaben.
Hier.
Milf? Da.
Den Namen kann man sich wenigstens merken.
Den 55 Zoll Amazon-TV für 190 gesehen?
Nö.
Das Ding, guck, du kriegst noch 50 Euro Coupon dabei
und da kostet es am Ende 9 Euro für vier Stück.
Aber wahrscheinlich ist es echt schrottig, ja?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Wenn sich flashen lässt, könnten die wirklich gut sein.
Okay, lass mal gucken. 55 Zoll.
Für 100, was?
Wo gibt es denn den? Für 190.
Wahnsinn! Amazon schleudert.
Ja.
Ach, morgen um 7.30 Uhr.
Wait a minute.
Das ist ein
Amazon Fire TV.
Okay.
Der hat aber schon HDMI-Input, oder?
Okay, der hat HDMI-Input.
Und Netzwerk.
Energieklasse G.
Der haut wahrscheinlich ordentlich was raus.
Aber ich meine,
da ist ja auch noch was dran.
Das heißt, ich mag eigentlich die Android-TV-Oberfläche.
Aber das ist mir sehr veramazonifiziert hier alles.
Fraglich ist auch,
ob man den deploaden kann.
Ich meine, dass man hier jetzt nicht die krasseste Sache kriegt
für den Preis, ist ja klar.
Was, Shield haben sie echt im Angebot?
Ach ja, tatsächlich.
Also da muss ich echt mal Nvidia loben an der Stelle.
Ich habe ja noch
das ganz alte Shield-TV.
Nicht mit dieser komisch dreieckigen Fernbedienung.
Aber das ist noch das ganz alte Shield-TV.
Ich meine, das sieht immer noch ein bisschen so aus wie das hier,
aber hat eine andere Fernbedienung dabei.
Die ich auch gar nicht benutze.
Und das funktioniert wirklich seit Jahren.
Ja, was Nvidia da geritten hat,
diesen komischen Zigarettenanzünder jetzt zu bauen, verstehe ich nicht.
Hier, mein Wohnzimmer-Setup.
So.
Und ich glaube, da hatte ich das Shield-TV sogar schon eine Weile.
Die Nvidia-Ente, ganz wichtig.
Guck mal, und das ist sechs Jahre her.
Und gehen wir mal davon aus,
ich hatte das da vielleicht schon zwei, drei Monate.
Also ehrlich, das ist jetzt
über, sag mal, sechseinhalb Jahre alt.
Das Setup hier.
Und das Ding funktioniert astrein.
Da kannst du echt nichts sagen.
Ich würde mir auch nichts anderes mehr holen.
Das Shield-TV funktioniert einfach top.
Also dafür kann man durchaus 180 Euro ausgeben.
Das richtig Gute am Shield-TV ist halt auch,
da ist ein offizielles Android-TV drauf.
Und die unterstützen halt auch die ganzen offiziellen Apps
von Amazon, von Netflix, von sonst wie.
Das heißt, du kannst da auch alles DRM-geschützte kaufen.
Ohne, dass du einen Kopfstand machen musst.
Du bekommst noch Updates.
Ja, du hast letztens erst ein Update gekriegt.
Ja, ja, ja.
What's new in 9.1.
Was hältst du vom Shield-TV ohne Pro?
Weiß ich nicht. Ich hab halt nur das alte Shield-TV.
Das sieht aus wie das Shield-TV Pro und
funktioniert.
Das hieß damals, glaube ich, noch nicht Shield-TV Pro.
Shield-TV Pro Amazon, oder?
Nice, das ist sehr laut, Max.
Guck, damals hieß es einfach nur Shield-TV Media Streaming Player.
Was hast du eigentlich für einen Bürostuhl?
Ja, wann kam das Update hier? Haben die da ein Datum stehen?
Kann ich euch sagen, wann das Update kam?
Shield Experience 9.1. Na, okay, ist schon ein bisschen her.
Shield-TV Update 2023.
Also, das Ding ist wirklich gut.
Ja, das ohne sieht kacke aus.
Also, das ohne Pro ist halt so ein Zigarettenanzünder.
Weiß nicht, was die sich da designtechnisch überlegt haben.
Was hast du eigentlich für einen Bürostuhl?
Ich hab einen
Sedus Mr.24
Swivel Chair.
Dieses Ding hier.
Sieht unscheinbar aus, ist aber der beste Bürostuhl, den ich kenne.
Und ich meine das ernst.
Nicht einfach nur random gesagt.
Das ist...
Ich hab auf keinem Stuhl länger gesessen.
Ich habe teilweise auf diesem Stuhl
20 Stunden am Stück gesessen.
Kein Witz. Wisst ihr warum?
Weil ich den daheim habe und früher auf der Arbeit hatten wir den auch.
Ich hab 8 Stunden auf der Arbeit gehockt.
Und dann nochmal 8 Stunden daheim gehockt.
Okay, 20 vielleicht ein bisschen übertrieben.
Aber ich hab 16 Stunden am Stück auf dem Stuhl quasi gesessen.
Und dir tut nicht der Arsch weh.
Also das ist wirklich ein nicer Chair.
Das einzige Problem bei dem Stuhl ist,
dass der leider
etwas teuer ist.
Für PepoFat Leute ist der optimal.
Der hält bis zu 250 Kilo glaube ich aus.
Also ich kann mich da richtig drauf pfeffern
und es geht nichts kaputt.
Der ist ein bisschen teuer. Ich hab den damals glaube ich für 1200 Euro gekauft.
Da war er auch schon ein bisschen im Angebot.
Und der hat halt auch nie Probleme gehabt.
Nie.
Und du kriegst auch für alles Ersatzteile.
Es klappert nix.
Es ist alles noch top.
Oh ich muss mein eigenes Video anmachen, damit ich Viewtime bekomme.
Wichtig.
Wie kann man denn sowas den Leuten
als Arbeitsplatzstuhl hinstellen?
MonkaS
Das ist ja Körperverletzung.
Ich hab schon drauf gesessen auf manchen.
Aber ganz ehrlich,
mein Stuhl ist mir der liebste, den ich hab.
Also ich hätte mir den nicht gekauft
für so viel Geld.
Hätte ich den nicht vorher schon lange ausprobiert
auf der Arbeit schon lange.
Und ich hätte mir keinen 1200 Euro Stuhl für daheim gekauft,
wenn ich nicht gewusst hätte, dass der was taugt.
Das ist keine Online-Casino-Musik.
Das ist eine Nintendo-Playlist.
Die habt ihr? Echt?
Auch die gleichen?
Mit welcher Kopfstütze habt ihr die?
Welchen Stuhl hast du genommen?
Den hier.
Den habe ich nicht heute gekauft.
Den habe ich schon seit 10 Jahren oder so.
Nein, seit 10 Jahren habe ich den nicht.
Da hatte ich noch so einen komischen DX-Racer,
der dann auseinandergebrochen ist.
Aber, sag mal, seit 8 Jahren oder so
habe ich den schon.
Schlechtes WLAN? Moin.
Darf ich meinen Repeater anschließen?
Wobei, der macht das WLAN nicht wirklich besser.
Er hat den nicht gebaut.
Ich glaube, wir hatten schon mal schlechtes WLAN hier im Chat,
jetzt wo ich deinen Namen lese.
Das ist nicht zufällig dein Zweitaccount, oder?
Egal, jetzt haben wir schlechtes WLAN und schlechtes WLAN.
Danke für den Sub übrigens.
Hast du mit Kopfstütze?
Ja.
Allerdings habe ich nicht diese gebogene,
sondern die gerade Kopfstütze.
Na, wenn es nach dem Typ im Video geht,
ist ja in 2-3 Jahren hat jeder das Handy dann live.
Leute, ich sehe gerade, was ist denn da los?
Was ist jetzt, Chat?
Ihr wisst es genau.
Sag doch mal was, ich habe das ganz vergessen,
dass Badge-Time ist.
Einfach Badge vergessen.
Raid-Time? Wieso, wen soll ich raiden?
Ich gehe jetzt ins...
Wir sehen uns, Leute.
Auf YouTube?
Ach, ist das der deutsche Internet-Historian?
Was macht er denn?
Ja, ich weiß, E-Mail-Leak.
Ist er am Start?
Der hat uns auch schon ein paar Mal gehostet,
da können wir uns wieder revanchieren.
Okay, komm, machen wir mal.
Raid.
Follow- oder Subscriber-only-Chat.
Wie jetzt?
Was ist da los?
Wir sehen uns, macht es gut. Bis dann.